Speaker 1: Let's go back to discord
and hear from a few more people.
David Pacman, dot com slash discord is the
place to go. Let's go to Jennie-O from Chester.
I guess it's a very complicated thing or
I don't know which is the name and which
is the location. Jennie-O. Welcome.
Speaker 2: Hi, David. How are you.
Speaker 1: Doing? Well.
Speaker 2: Awesome. Great to speak to you again.
I just hopped on so I didn't have a question
ready. Although I'm. What do you think? Are you
fan a fan of Sean King, the activist?
Speaker 1: No, I'm not.
Speaker 2: Oh, what are your reasons for that?
Speaker 1: I don't want to make this a whole
thing. Listen, I basically. I'm trying to
figure out how to do this without, like,
saying things that aren't public. My understanding
is that there is a sizable grift going on there,
and it's never been my sort of activism
that I've seen them engage in. And honestly,
I didn't think he was active any more. I haven't
heard anyone mention his name for years. I mean,
maybe he's still doing stuff. But I thought that
he had kind of gone gone silent some years ago.
Speaker 2: Oh, okay. Yeah, he's on Instagram and,
you know, I don't think he's as big as he was. But
yeah, that was my question for a day.
Thank you so much, love. I love your show.
Speaker 1: All right, there goes Jennie-O.
Hopefully that doesn't make it any trouble.
Who the hell knows? These days, anything can
get you into trouble. Why don't we go next to
John from Salt Lake City, Utah, the center
of the Church of Latter Day Saints. John,
welcome to the program. What's on your mind today?
Speaker 2: Yeah. I just have one question. What
do you think of the recent news that at least
some Russian partizans invaded Russian city
of Belgorod? You didn't see that? That
could have been like our special forces
in there. Or maybe encouraging them,
training them, something like that.
Speaker 1: I have not heard of that at
all. I'm going to have to research that.
I watched. When did this happen?
Speaker 2: This was like, I think
it was yesterday or the day before.
Speaker 1: Geez. No, I haven't seen
that yet. And so the idea is that it may
not be what it actually appears to be.
Speaker 2: Yeah. So what I'm thinking is maybe
they got training from, like NATO forces in order
to do something like that or like they're,
like, directly involved in a way you said.
Speaker 1: That's interesting. So what I'm reading
is it seems Russia has not invaded, but rather
Belgorod, the Russian border region, was attacked
by an armed group crossing from Ukraine. There's a
couple sources saying that Russia accused Ukraine
of being responsible Ukraine. Ukraine denied it
and said the attackers were Russian citizens
from paramilitary groups that oppose Putin.
It seems we really don't know right now what
the truth is. That's what I'm gathering, Josh.
Speaker 2: Because from what
the pictures that I've seen,
it looks like it could have been equipment that
we donated. I saw a couple of Humvees in there.
Speaker 1: Yet, listen, that's so speculative.
I just don't know. I would be cautious about
making a definitive statements right now.
Speaker 2: I mean, I don't want to really
hop on one bandwagon or the other. I just
want to see a little bit more details,
you know what I'm saying? Yeah.
Speaker 1: Yeah. I want to know the
truth of what happened. From what I'm seeing, I'm
looking at five sources and they don't agree on
what happened right now.
Speaker 2:
Yeah. All right. Thank you very much. All right.
Speaker 1: Appreciate it. Yeah. We're
going to have to look more into that. Maybe by
next week we'll have more more information. But
that's that's quite a wild situation. Let's go
to Brett from Chicago. Brett, welcome to the
program. What's on your mind today?
Speaker 2: Hey, can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 2: Yeah. Yeah. I'm glad
to report from a winning part of the country in a
few different ways. I mean, we just got the most
progressive mayor in history elected here. And I'm
also originally from Minnesota. And a lot of great
thing. I don't know if you've been hearing about
that. A lot of it, great things have been coming
out of like the Minnesota legislature recently.
Speaker 1: I heard I heard some we covered one
story. Yeah. I mean, so you're feeling good about
the part of the country you're in, it sounds like.
Speaker 2: Yeah. Yeah. Honestly, I'm a member
of the local. Why do DSA say here, you know,
the Democratic Socialists of America. And we were
pretty excited. We didn't endorse Brandon Johnson
directly because he's not like a socialist,
but pretty heavily. I think he got support
from our sector, a lot of activity going out and
doing work on the ground, canvasing, talking to
people at polling stations and that sort of thing.
Speaker 1: So, Brett, as a as an actual democratic
socialist yourself, I'm curious, do you align
with the socialist perspective of socializing
ownership of businesses? Like is that something
businesses should be required to do by government?
Speaker 2: I'm I'm definitely on the. I guess
you'd call it the more conservative side of the
Democratic Socialists. It's a pretty big tent
party as far as like, current, like practical
boots on the ground activism. Yeah, well,
we're I what we are advocating for isn't like,
you know, it isn't normally that extra
like. Turning all businesses into co-ops
immediately through an executive order. I mean,
a lot of people, again, in the organization
disagree with me on that. You know.
Speaker 1: Asking you like, what would
be your biggest socialist belief, would you say?
Speaker 2: Yeah, I would say that like I would be
in favor of things as straight, as extreme as
probably like breaking up large corporations,
making more things like publicly now publicly
owned like re, like the private D, privatizing,
like infrastructure, things like that. I mean,
like, start with the like the big things where
it seems very reasonable that you and I would
probably agree on like public transport or,
you know, things that like other countries
socialized and socialized well. Yeah. And
then I would probably keep moving
forward on that until it stops being
effective. But. But so are you sure.
Speaker 1: You're a socialist? That's
interesting. It's I mean, there's you're
it sounds like you're more of like a
social Democrat, which is a form of capitalism.
Speaker 2: Yeah. Yeah. I mean, in the midterm,
it seems to be that way. But like, I would
like a like having the means of production,
being socialized, being out, like large
industries, being collectively owned,
that seems like a good thing to me is just how
we get there. Like social democracy, like I'm an
electoral less. I'm a, you know, a slow, gradual
movement. So in the in the short to medium term,
I do look effectively like a social Democrat.
Speaker 1: So your view is sort of like that
espoused by Ian Roush, the streamer where
he says in the immediate really socialists
and social Democrats probably would agree on the
same policies, just that if they were achieved,
then the socialists would want to go further.
Speaker 2: Yeah. Oh gosh, I'm getting outed
here for agreeing with Bosch. So that's going to
be it's going to be great because I realize that
way because a lot of people in the
DSA are not and not fans of his.
Speaker 1: They're anti-Bush. That's interesting.
Speaker 2: Yeah, the big anti-abortion
movement is probably a big anti
David Packman movement as well.
Speaker 1: Oh, obviously. No, listen, there's no
doubt there's an anti David Pacman movement among
the socialists. That's that's without a doubt.
Speaker 2: But yeah, that's me. Before you.
Before you let me go, David, I've got to
add, I should, like, represent that I am
more left in a way and actually ask you a
somewhat difficult question, or at least
it might it might not be difficult. Okay, please.
Because you get a lot of criticism from the left,
specifically on your coverage of South America
And like Latin American politics, I'm sure you.
Speaker 1: Know, But I mean, I only I know
years ago something about Bolivia, but I
didn't know that that was like an ongoing thing.
Speaker 2: Oh, okay. So maybe you're not. Okay.
So there are, like, a few things. It's not
like massive, but like, I wonder if you have
any updates on that one story you covered because
you got some heat from that in my circles. Anyway,
when you covered, I believe it was in Argentina,
there was an assassination attempt and the way
you presented it was you were like very suspicious
of it and like kind of suggesting that it may have
been something like a false flag or, you know,
like that. It wasn't a real assassination attempt.
And this was pretty like immediate after the.
Speaker 1: Oh, no. I think I mean, that was a
while ago. I don't know if I didn't speak clearly
or if maybe you're misremembering it or I am.
But it was more the idea that these that sort of
hijinx is the stuff I wouldn't put past Cristina,
but I was very, very clear that it was not
something I was asserting took place or I mean,
I was super clear that it's merely speculative
and that there are people wondering about it,
but that it was such an, you know, off handed
thing. I wasn't putting a lot of stock in it.
I wasn't trying to convince anyone of that.
I mean, it was just it was just a you know,
it's just casual conversation.
Speaker 2: Oh, okay. Okay. Fair
enough. Yeah, I some people get pretty antsy
about it, like that sort of speculation. But,
you know, because people are afraid, because
they're like the what? The slightly more
left party and I'm sure like center left.
Speaker 1: I mean, listen, I'll be honest. What
I can tell you is I think Cristina is completely
out of her mind. I mean, cuckoo for Cocoa Puffs. I
don't know if you've been following her recently,
but seems completely disconnected from reality.
But that's probably a story for another day.
Speaker 2: Of showing up. Well, thank you
very much for having me on, David. All right.
Speaker 1: Brett from Chicago. Worried about
worried about agreeing with the invocation.
Hopefully he doesn't get in trouble.